So, we created this website in less than
5 minutes, and it costed us less than $1
to create it. In today's video, I'll be
attempting to create, optimize, and
launch a website in less than 5 minutes.
Let's go ahead and get started. Timer
starts now. So, I'll be using Rank
sites, which is my new tool that allows
you to spin up SEO-optimized websites in
a matter of minutes. So, first let's go
ahead and we're going to create an
account.
We're going to do a local service
business.
I'm going to give a name to the
business. So, I've already went ahead
and got this information from ChatGPT.
So, I'm just making up a business here,
but of course you'd want to put in your
actual business information.
So, I'm going to get our example phone
number. So, everything here is going to
be correct, up-to-date.
We're going to get our tagline here as
well.
And then we're going to Dallas,
Texas. I'm going to continue.
Then for the description of the
business, we're going to just copy over
all of this information. So, essentially
you can just copy over this prompt here.
We're going to have a way for you to
copy over the prompt, pop it into
ChatGPT with your business information.
You're just essentially going to tell it
what you do, the services you offer, the
locations you offer, and things of that
nature. So, now we're going to add in
the actual services again here.
So, [music] let's go over to
services
right here. So, I'm not going to add in
all of these services because um it will
obviously take a little bit longer, but
we're going to add in at least four to
five of these services [music]
here.
So, once we add it in, as you can see,
it's going to be tagged onto our
website, and these are going to be the
services that we're offering.
We're going to add that in. Now, for
areas again, we're going to do the same
thing. We're going to copy over the
areas.
So, again, because this is in Texas, we
have Austin, we have Houston,
we have
Phoenix.
Okay, so that's a good amount of
locations here. We have Let's go ahead
and we'll add one more.
Because this is a more general website,
it has more general cities, but of
course, if you're targeting a specific
city itself, then it'll only have that
city. I've I've already generated um
a logo as well, so we're going to use
that logo. We're going [music] to go
with a I think actually we were able to
get the color code here, so we want it
to be very, very specific. So, we're
going to use this specific color of
teal.
So, as you can see, we can change our
color. Go to continue for Formspree.
So, I've already went ahead and created
a Formspree account, so all I have to do
is copy over the API key, but again,
this takes you like a couple of seconds
to set up as well. Doesn't take you
very, very long.
So, then we're going to go back over
here. We're going to paste in our
endpoint. Go to continue.
Last thing we need to do is add in our
OpenRouter [music] API key. So, again,
I've already went ahead and copied over
my OpenRouter API key.
So, we're going to paste that in.
Validate. It is validated. And now,
we're going to click generate with AI
and publish.
So, this is sort of the first initial
website that we'll be getting. And as
you can see here, it took us less than 5
minutes. We still have about 4 minutes
left. Right? So, if I look at the time,
about a minute uh and 20 left. So, under
4 minutes, we're able to generate this
site. Let's go ahead and take a look at
it.
Right? So, it looks pretty good. We have
our services there, all the services
that we offered. Right? [music] We have
the
Uh if you scroll down as well, we have
the location pages here as well.
Right? We have the location pages.
Uh the areas that we service, the
homepage. Um obviously, we can go ahead
and edit this. We can add imagery here.
We can update our content. Uh but most
importantly, we have a form here as
well, and our form actually works. So,
this form works as well. From going into
our service pages, this has our CTA.
It has internal linking. All the content
right now is placeholder, so we can
further add any content that we like.
And that was all under 5 minutes. Now,
if you want to take this a step further,
right? Now we have a site that's
actually published. So, this site is
published. So, right away, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to touch test
our page speed insights.
And we're going to see how we're doing
here.
Right? But now we can actually go ahead,
we can start generating our content. So,
we can generate more in-depth content
for our services, for our location
pages.
Um and even start generating our blog
posts and articles as well.
So, we're we're going to give this a
couple of seconds here.
Our 5-minute timer is now gone. But
again, as you were able to see, we were
able to publish a site in 5 minutes or
less. And we can see here from our
performance on PageSpeed, we have 97
performance, 95 accessibility,
100 best practices, and 100 SEO, and
three out of three agentic browsing for
our website. And that brings me to
another point. Our website is also
mobile optimized. So, we can see here it
is responsive, right? It is not a
website that only looks good on desktop.
It looks good on any uh field. And once
you add our images, everything comes to
life. Right? But as you can see here,
you were able to build a mobile
optimized SEO optimized
website in a matter of
5 minutes or less. So, you can do this
for yourself or you can do this for a
client so much easier.
And it really makes creating sites so
much easier. So, again, we're going back
over to our location and our services
pages. This again is going to use our
OpenRouter API key. So, if I head back
over to OpenRouter,
um it's still generating, so it's going
to take you a couple of seconds. But, as
you can see, it's using our Claude
Sonnet 4.6 model, and usually costs you
less than 10 cents. So, this is costing
us about 6 cent uh to create a page.
Okay, so now our services pages just
finished. So, we can see here our AI
data center site selection, that page
has been generated
um with the content. Here's the content.
So, CoreGrid AI infrastructure helps
growing companies identify, compare, and
select, blah blah blah. Right? So, it's
actually went ahead and included our
business information as well. Um we have
our highlights cards, which I'll be
showing you guys what that looks like in
just 1 second. Now, we can create a
service page hero. So, if I wanted to, I
can go over and I can
copy over
um what this page is about.
Just added in a very sim- simple prompt
here, nothing too crazy. And we're going
to click start generating. So, it's
actually going to use our OpenRouter key
to also generate images as well. And
those images you can then use throughout
the website. So, let's just go ahead and
click publish for this page, the
location page as well. That's also been
uh generated. And again, as you can see
here, it's using our actual business
information and the city information.
And also, their schema has been
attached. So, our local business schema
has been attached as well. So, schema is
also included
um within every single one of these
pages.
So, we can click publish and we also
have the ability to index this page. So,
if I click index this page, this will
then I don't want to do it right now
because we're on a um temporary domain.
Um but you can actually go ahead
and tell the AI to index this page. So,
this page would then be sent over to our
indexing tool and then we can see the
report of how that um
URL has been indexed on Google. So, we
we're also automating indexing your
content because it's wanting to create
the content, create the website, but if
it's not showing up in Google, then it's
a waste of time. So, not only is are you
creating your content, you're also
indexing it so it shows up to increase
the likeness that you can actually rank
these pages. So, I'm going to click
publish on both of these. We're going to
publish the site. We can see now the
services now only includes the one
service that we've generated because now
it's only going to include um it's only
going to include content that we
actually customize and enhanced. Right?
So, we see here this is the article.
This is what it looks like. We get a
nice sidebar menu here. Everything looks
great. We get our elements and we can
edit any of these elements if we need.
And then we get our CTA as well. So,
going back over to the homepage, again,
I can
go over to my site. And guys, just keep
in mind that I did all of this on a
completely free plan. I was able to do
this on a completely free plan, build up
my website
for uh completely free here. So, now we
can edit the page. We can actually go
ahead and if we go go to choose image,
this is the image that we just
generated, right? Um so, we can actually
use that image on this page. We can use
it on the FAQ. So, again, we can go to
publish. If I go back here, let's go to
the service page. I can now add this as
a service page as well. Click publish
and then we can publish our website. So
again, we did this on a completely free
plan of Rank Site. We did not pay any
money. Only thing we're using is our
OpenRouter API key. And if you go back
over to OpenRouter,
we haven't spent a dollar. We've spent
if you take a look at our image here,
our image cost is going to be the
highest. Um we've spent 16 6
um you know, right this is all. So we've
spent we've spent, sorry, less than a
dollar. So we created this website in
less than 5 minutes and it costed us
less than $1 to create it. If you
enjoyed this video and you want to try
out Rank Site for yourselves, there'll
be an exclusive
discount in description below today's
video because we are still early. So if
you are a early adopter, you'll get the
highest discounted prices for Rank Site.
It will continue to increase in pricing
and eventually we're going to be just a
subscription-only model. So if you guys
want to take advantage of these early
days and lock in your pricing, there'll
be a link below. Thank you. Take care
and I'll see you in the next one.